So now that you've learned about search trees and pre-processing,
you already know quite a lot about the loopholes
that we can find in the laws of NP-completeness
in order to actually tackle an NP-complete problem,
because now you can get from algorithms that
would normally take 2 to the power of N time
down to other algorithms that say take
1.3 to the power of N time,
which already makes many more instances solvable.
But to conclude this unit,
I want to show you another loophole in the
laws of NP-completeness that is sometimes very, very useful
and that actually not very many people know about.
So I'm going to state another law from the book of NP-completeness,
and that law in which we will soon poke loopholes is
larger instances are harder to solve.
And that is actually quite obvious because we said that we were going to look at
worse case time and always measure the running time of an  algorithm
as a function of the input size.
Say we have an algorithm that runs in O of 2 to the power of N times N squared time.
What this law here means is bigger and more time in worst-case scenario.
So if you have a running time like this,
a bigger input size means more running time required for the
algorithm in a worst-case scenario.
Let's talk a little bit about this N here, the size of the input,
because this is often a very coarse estimate of
how hard an input is actually to solve,
and I'm going to give you one example of this
or actually I'm going to quiz you about this.
Given the search trees and the pre-processing,
which of the following instances of vertex cover is easier to solve?
And I know this is an easy one.
In case you're wondering,
the number of vertices in each of the graphs here is the same.